Our founders never intended us to have a professional political class.
They believed that citizens and leaders needed to step forward.
We know the only way to reimagine our government is to reimagine who is leading it.
I'm Carly Fiorina and I'm running for president.
If you're tired of the sound bites, the vitriol, the pettiness, the egos, the corruption,...
...if you believe that it's time to declare the end of identity politics,...
...if you believe that it's time to declare the end of lowered expectations,...
...if you believe that it's time for citizens to stand up to the political class...
...and say: "Enough," then join us.
It's time for us to empower our citizens,...
...to give them a voice in our government,...
...to come together to fix what has been broken about our politics and our government for too long,...
...because we can do this together.